foreign
let's go north of the border to Ontario
and talk to Cindy what's up Cindy
hey Cindy
um you're Sydney
sorry I'm a little nervous hi doctor
I'll go by Cindy I'll go by sending this
call you go by John I'll go by Cindy
let's do this this would be hyper
confusing all right so what's up
um well thank you for taking my call I'm
a huge fan of yours and I listen to your
show every day
um I'm a little bit obsessed hey um hey
there's only there's about 22 of us now
so thank you for being one of the few
it's awesome
so you're welcome
um the reason for my call today is about
my husband's alcohol addiction
um I have two questions one my family
and I want to know how to deal with my
husband's drinking at family functions
and parties
and two is limiting his access to funds
considered Financial abuse if I'm
protecting our finances from his
addiction
so let me unpack that a bit so that you
can get some background on what's
Happening
um I'm a bit nervous and I I don't want
to forget anything so I hope you don't
mind me reading from my notes no that's
great
um okay great
um I feel like my my children and I are
being gaslighted by my husband about his
addiction
um we ask him ahead of family functions
or parties to either not drink or to
limit his drinking and he'll promise but
he rarely keeps it and especially if he
has access to unlimited uh beer like a
wedding or special occasion
so at parties he'll help himself to
other people's beer after he's finished
his own which angers me so much because
it's not they're not his to take
um
is timetable basically revolves around
work and drinking after work he works in
the evenings most nights so on those
night tea drinks
um his five tall cans and goes to bed if
he's off work for the day he usually
starts drinking by three in the
afternoon
how old are your kids
um they're adults they're both close 30.
how long have you been living with this
um probably about that long
are you done
no I'm not I'm not done why why
you lived with this for so long
why
he's such a good person and
I don't want to split up the family I we
both came from broken homes and I don't
want to ever I just don't want it Cindy
family Cindy you are living in a fantasy
you didn't break this family up
your husband chose to
not heal from his addiction not get the
help he needed
and for 30 years he's told you that
you have to do this and you're the
reason for this and
you've had to manage that and you had
two kids grow up in this mess with an
alcoholic father
yep and you've got guilt over that
and you've got guilt over all of it
enough
you're not breaking this family up Cindy
you're staying safe and I think he can
be a
um
I don't want to touch a morality to it
but the good men in my life do hard
things on behalf of their wives and kids
the men in my life the good men in my
life the people I would say that's a
good man
looks in a mirror and says I've got to
be different starting now I've screwed
up and I have to make major changes
I know good good men who've cheated on
their spouses and they've taken a knee
and said I screwed this thing up I know
good men who've stolen and who've lied
and said here's where I'm going to be on
the back end of that car wreck
and your husband is chosen
not to remain an addict but he has
chosen to not get help
he um one time said that he was going to
go into rehab and I was crying tears of
happiness and
it then um coveted hit and he ended up
talking to an addiction counselor over
the phone and then it just stopped and
he went back to his drinking and you
went back to your fantasy
yeah I guess so
I'm not in the business of telling
people to get divorced that's not what I
do
I am in the business of telling people
that they deserve to be loved and they
deserve to be well and you deserve to
have a night of sleep and you deserve to
go to a party and laugh and have joy and
not worry that the person you brought is
going to make a drunken fool of
themselves and hurt people
yeah
you deserve to tell your kids I'm so
sorry
I didn't stand up for you all earlier in
this mess
and from this point forward we're going
to do different things you can do that
or you can make peace with the fact that
I'm choosing to stay with an alcoholic
and this is what that comes with
that's the choice you can make too but
what you're doing is you're trying to
have one thing while doing the other
thing and you're making yourself crazy
yeah right
yes gotta own the reality
nothing you've tried in 30 years would
give you any data any sort of indication
that he's going to quit drinking is that
fair
yes that's true okay so let's let's just
take that as a given he has chosen
alcohol as his way of coping with the
hard stuff in his past and in his
present and potentially in his future
so the only thing you can control is
your thoughts and your actions
[Music]
he came up with an agreement a few years
ago
because I told him I'm sick of his
drinking and
I told him that what is this what does
his drinking do to you does he does he
hit you
no oh God no he's he's wonderful in
every other way
he is a happy drunk he doesn't get
abusive in any way at all why do you
want to quit drinking then
it's the drunkenness it's the behavior
he said you said he's wonderful
conversation he said he's lovely
wonderful he's a happy guy
inside of his drink
ing okay
yeah when he's under the influence he
basically just sits easily with his head
down and just kind of you can't really
have a normal conversation with him he
just he gets this look in his face that
just
it's just not
um how many days a week how many days a
week does he drink
seven
so when is he this happy-go-lucky guy he
drinks every day
if the evening during the day he doesn't
he doesn't drink at work he doesn't
drink at home when
when
we're off it's it usually if he's off
during the day he'll start around three
o'clock in the afternoon
and
he'll usually be in bed by eight or nine
and during the week when he comes home
from work because he works weeknights a
lot Cindy
you're not being honest with yourself
you're not being honest with yourself
you're telling yourself things that are
simply not true
all right
this has to be incredibly expensive
it is
he was spending
before about five or six hundred a month
and
we got it down to 300 now
but he will
what I've actually done is I opened up a
bank account in my own name and I put
all the bills through that account and
he agreed to this I transfer over ten
dollars a day which will get him five
tall cam
and
and then he'll call me and say can you
top it up I need a bit of gas or I need
lunch money and then he'll spend some of
that on more beer and if I say that to
him he'll stay it's my money I worked
for it it's my money just transfer it
over and then he's going out driving
around on recycling days looking for
empty beer cans and liquor bottles so he
can take them back for the deposit and
he'll use that to top up his drinking
it's just ridiculous but you contribute
you participate
[Applause]
you're giving him an alcohol allowance
Cindy
and he's right you
I know I know
I know
[Applause]
if I give him free reign he'll go back
to spending between 16 and 24 a day you
cannot control what another adult
chooses to do you can only control you
you are not I understand that you're not
his mother this is our finances I know
you aren't safe Cindy
foreign
do you work
yes I do
are you would you be able to support
yourself
um
probably yeah
if you reached out to your two 30 year
old kids and said it's time would they
weep tears of joy and come help you
or they say hi they would
yeah
they have a lot of issues with him and
yeah I imagine so why do you think so
little of yourself
um and that's a mean unfair question I
know but why because the person I'm
hearing on the phone is a person who's
not had enough
and you're not dumb you're real smart
[Music]
I guess because my we both came for
broken families I don't I don't want to
be that person I want to make things
work I keep trying to work I know your
heart's so good you're fit it's already
broken
okay
what you have is a home on the inside of
it that's completely burned out and you
keep repainting the exterior
and you're that and you can stand out in
the front yard and be like look at this
home look how nice it is
it's not and you know that
in the ultimate I know you are I can
hear it on you
in the ultimate form of
I guess you can call it gaslighting
you've now become
your marriage has been weaponized now
now it's your fault if he does or
doesn't drink now you're stealing his
money you see how you've become the
villain in this by trying to keep him
alive
yeah you're not the bad guy you are
participating make no mistake
and I know you feel stuck I get that
but at the end of the day he's a
grown-up and he's an alcoholic and he's
choosing to drink his and to hide
what should I do in terms of finances
I think you need to sit down with one of
your older kids
and be very very clear on a spreadsheet
or a yellow pad for crying out loud
possibly get with a financial planner
and get a very clear reality of where
you live
how much debt do you owe what is rent in
the area cost all those hard questions
but at some point you walk in and you
say I'm not going to be your mom anymore
I try to keep you alive for 30 years and
in the process of about darn near killed
myself
oh you don't love me anymore you're not
gonna no
okay
I love you so much that I'm not going to
carry this anymore
not yet right I'm not your social worker
I'm not your mom I'm your wife
yeah
and I'm not going to go down on the ship
with you
and these are so these are I can think
of very few boundaries that are harder
when somebody that you love is actively
struggling with addiction actively
hurting themselves and at some point you
say
I love you but you can't do that here
and if you do that here you are by your
actions because behavior is a language
you are asking me to leave
because I'm worth more than this and you
know if I leave he's going to drink
himself sideways
and that is a choice a grown-up is going
to make
you can call the police and have them do
a welfare check you can call social
services and see if they'll reach out
and you can walk with him hold his hand
into rehab or into a counseling you can
go
but you can't make him stop drinking
no
I could take my 12 year old and lock him
in the house I can do that you can't do
that with him
no
and Cindy I I'm heartbroken for you I
can hear it on you love this man
I think that you love the idea of this
man
I think you love the story about this
man that you've told yourself for a long
long time
mm-hmm
and I think this man's redeemable I
think everybody is I really do
he's gonna have to choose Redemption you
can't push him into it
no I realized that and that's so hard
yep if I'm you if you're if you're my
wife if you're my well even my wife but
if you were my mom if you were my sister
I would tell you to call your two kids
and y'all go have an in-person meeting
if at all possible
and say I'm exploring
taking care of myself for the first time
in 30 years
I'm exploring being safe for the first
time in 30 years
I need some help with finances I need
some help with what comes next I need
some help talking to Dad
I'm gonna need to get a alcohol
counselor and see if we can get over
here and do one last intervention
and put some very strong boundaries in
place
and I'm gonna have to do the Nitty
Gritty of finding out what a one bedroom
apartment costs
and then man you're gonna have to grieve
it because you've been propping up this
picture of a perfect family for a long
time because you didn't want this to
happen and it did and we have to own
what happened and I've said this before
I'll say it again
the world is begging you Cindy and
everybody listening
not to keep replaying and propping up
these old pictures but to ask to ask
ourselves in that mirror
what are we going to do now
what are we gonna do now that's the
question all of us are asking